everyone is Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update Halloween is just
around the corner and Los Santos is
getting in the mood with a new
multiplayer update for grand theft auto
5 the new update is titled Halloween
surprise and will run from now until
November 16th the update includes new
vehicles masks face paint in a new
gameplay type called slasher adversary
mode the two new spooky cars in the
update include the lurcher hearse and
the frankenstein you can also now add 20
new ghoulish bobbleheads to the
dashboard of your customizable lowrider
these items will only be available until
November 16 fortunately if you pick them
up or purchase items beforehand they
will remain in your inventory after the
event has ended the new slasher
adversary mode is an asymmetrical game
type or one players equipped with a
shotgun and designated as the slasher
the other players equipped with the new
flashlight must survive in the dark for
3 minutes while the slasher hunts them
down finally rock star now said there
will be a special halloween event this
weekend as well as a live stream on
October thirtieth at five p.m. eastern
if however you're playing Grand Theft
Auto 5 on old consoles like the Xbox 360
and ps3 you're out of luck the new
Halloween update only applies to ps4
xbox one and pc versions of the game so
we'll be jumping back into Grand Theft
Auto 5 this weekend to check out the
Halloween surprise we're scaring kids in
your neighborhood with your very
accurate trevor costume let us know in
the comments below stay tuned to
gamespot more Halloween related news